good afternoon thank you for joining me
at this press conference this afternoon
uh i am back in my office
after my self-imposed isolation i'm
wearing a mask because i've got staff in
here with me so
uh we're back to work back to normal i
hope all nevadans enjoyed a safe
and healthy thanksgiving holiday i'm
glad to provide you all today with an
update as we prepare for a covid19
vaccine which we anticipate may be
available
in the next week or so in limited on a
limited basis
thanks to the development of the
vaccines there is hope on the horizon
as i said earlier in my last press
conference we are closer to the end than
we are to the beginning and there is
definitely a light at the end of the
tunnel
there's no doubt that this vaccine these
vaccines will play a pivotal role
in helping combat this disease but it
will take time to make sure
everyone has access to the vaccine
it's critical to remember that federal
officials have widely reported that we
won't see
large-scale vaccinations throughout
america until the spring
so we need a bridge to get there to get
from now till then
here in our state that bridge between
today and the day that we have
large-scale vaccination
must be built by nevadans the tools
we have to build that bridge are the
same public health measures
we've all heard on repeat over the last
nine months
you've heard these before but i'm going
to repeat them for you again
avoid large gatherings limit exposure by
working from home and staying home as
much as possible
wash your hands wear a mask
that's all we have those are the tools
that we need to use
i'm going to spend a couple of minutes
giving an update on nevada's current
situation
one week into our statewide pause
our current status is proof that as of
today
our bridge is shaky we have a lot of
work to do and it will take all of us
to recommit ourselves to turning things
around before a vaccine
is widely available as many of you know
from watching the daily updates
we are not seeing a downtrend downward
trajectory
in any of the metrics that we are
tracking in fact
we continue to experience increases
across the board
as of today 16 of our 17 counties
that's right 16 out of 17 counties
have been flagged for elevated risk of
covet 19 transmission
to our state health officials covid 19
cases in nevada
are growing at a rate twice that of the
previous peak that we observed in july
daily hospitalizations are at an
all-time high
the 14-day test positivity rate is the
highest we have seen to date
and the number of daily deaths to cover
19
is on the rise the wildfire
spread of community spread continues to
grow out of control
and most concerningly our numbers do not
yet include any surge
from the thanksgiving holiday almost
every day
we are breaking the previous records i
am concerned that state health officials
are concerned
and if that's not enough i'd like to
share the recommendations and input
that was sent to us from the white house
task force this week
we are in a very dangerous quote we are
in a very dangerous place due to the
current
extremely high coveted baseline and
limited hospital capacity
a further post thanksgiving surge will
compromise covert patient care
as well as medical care overall
the rate of covid spread is increasing
in nevada
engage local leaders to demonstrate the
effect growing cases will have
on hospitals and overall patient care
if the vends don't change their
behaviors
all states and counties must flatten the
curve now
in order to sustain health systems both
coveted
and non-coveted emergencies need
new orders put in place by the governor
should result in a rapid decrease in
transmission
if compliance with those orders are high
to summarize if directives and
mitigation measures
were followed over thanksgiving and
continue to be followed
the white house believes we should see a
decline
one more time these are directly from
the white house
so if you are inclined to believe me
hopefully you'll listen to them
if best practices were not followed over
the thanksgiving holiday
these numbers will no doubt increase
as i mentioned last week if we do not
begin to see a change in our trajectory
and if this crisis continues to get
worse
we will be left in the unfortunate
position of having to take stronger
actions
something i've been desperately trying
to avoid in order to balance the
economic impacts
but i've been clear since the start we
cannot overwhelm our health care system
and put countless lives in danger
again there's hope on the horizon but we
must strengthen that bridge between now
and the day we have wide scale
vaccinations
back in october the nevada department of
health and human services submitted our
state playbook
for the covit 19 vaccine planning
to the center for disease control and
prevention referred to as the cdc
since then the planning document has
been adjusted as the overall vaccine
response has continued to develop
and to change while there are still some
unknowns we certainly know more than we
did this last time
that i spoke about this we're expecting
to have our first
allocation of covid19 vaccine from the
federal government
very soon potentially by the middle of
december
this timeline is still being determined
by the federal government
we are still awaiting what nevada's
first allocation of vaccines
will be once an allocation is sent to
nevada
our state team is ready to take on the
allocation
and begin redistributing it i'm proud of
this team
for maintaining close relationships with
our county and tribal partners in the
state
to ensure that allocations are
distributed as quickly as possible
with as much support as the state could
possibly provide
the tribal nations in nevada have all
elected receive their allocations
directly from the indian health services
which will be separate from the
allocations sent to the state overall
this close collaboration and planning is
what will help us ensure
as smooth a distribution as possible of
these brand new vaccines
nevada in addition to some of our other
western state partners joined the
covid19
scientific safety review work group
which is independently
reviewing the safety and efficacy of any
vaccine approved by the fda
for distribution the goal of the western
state safety coalition is to provide
nevadans
with an additional layer of confidence
when it comes to the covid19
vaccine this verification process is
happening in lockstep with the federal
approval agency process
it is not anticipated to cause any delay
in getting a safe vaccine to the
residents in these participating
states the work group has been charged
with staying abreast of vaccine
candidates
trials evidence of safety and efficacy
and other information to independently
provide recommendations
to state leadership and vaccine planning
efforts
as well as to ensure the public
confidence in vaccine safety
efficacy and implementation efforts
it is natural for the public to have
questions about a new vaccine
now remain committed to transparency
regarding vaccine planning
and expectations today i am joined
again by two of our experts on the
vaccine planning team
candace mcdaniel health bureau chief
bureau of child family and community
wellness
division of public and behavioral health
and shannon bennett
immunization program manager division of
public and behavioral health
they will provide an update to the
state's effort as we prepare for the
distribution
and administration of the safe vaccine
as supplies become available
with that i will now turn it over to
candice to provide an update
on nevada's vaccination planning efforts
candace
thank you governor we appreciate the
opportunity to join you today
and provide an update on the coven 19
vaccine planning
and distribution as you have seen there
are currently two vaccines that are
offering
promising results that have filed for
emergency use
authorization with the fda
pfizer and moderna are showing an early
efficacy of about 95
which is an inproportionate reduction
of disease in the vaccinated group so a
95
efficacy indicates a 95 reduction
in disease occurrence among the
vaccinated group
or a 95 reduction in the number of cases
you would expect if the group had not
been vaccinated
even with the promising efficacy
percentages
a vaccine will not be released for use
until it is deemed
safe and effective the fda
vaccines and related biological products
advisory committee
is set to meet on december 10th and from
there
that point we anticipate things will
move quickly
staff for the nevada state immunization
program are prepared
and will be on standby to accept initial
shipments
and for the redistribution when a
vaccine is received
since our last update we have continued
with our planning
and preparation for scenarios we may
encounter during the vaccine rollout
from these exercises we have developed a
more comprehensive process for
distribution
the nevada state immunization program is
receiving regular updates on both
vaccines and how they must be
shipped handled stored and administered
each of their we have a very own
specific challenges
and parameters that we are working with
we told you previously
about the ultra cold storage needed for
the covid 19 vaccine
the pfizer vaccine will require
ultracold storage
but the moderna vaccine will not both
vaccines
require two doses to be administered
with a set
time frame in between we continue to
work with our partners
statewide to share this information
ensure vaccinators are enrolled
and initial orders are submitted
allocations of the covid19 vaccine
will be made based on population and we
will use the tiered approach
in alignment with the advisory committee
on immunization practices guidance
to ensure our frontline medical
providers receive the first doses
i will now pass it over to shannon
bennett to talk about our tiered
approach
thank you candace thank you governor
as candace said nevada's playbook
outlines the tiered populations that
will receive the first doses of copin 19
vaccine
it is important to remember that when a
vaccine is approved for use
and allocated to individual states the
tiers we
developed will outline who is eligible
to receive the vaccine
our framework of priority populations
begins with those at the highest risk
risk for contracting covenant 19 and
those who are
who we are all depending on to take care
of us our critical infrastructure
workforce in hospitals
and medical facilities tier one also
includes other medical provider types
correctional facility staff and law
enforcement
oh for of this first vaccine allocation
a portion will also be set aside for cvs
and walgreens our pharmacy partners
who will work to vaccinate members of
our vulnerable population who work
and reside in long-term care facilities
we are working with all nevada counties
to finalize their plans to vaccinate
vaccinate their tier 1 population an
important consideration when vaccinating
medical facility staff
is the potential for anticipated side
effects
as with other vaccines a low-grade fever
and a sore arm or indication the vaccine
is doing its job
but it may impact our medical
workforce's ability to do theirs for a
short amount of time
as we have planned for vaccine rollout
we are planning with our medical
facilities to ensure
only a portion of the staff receive the
vaccine at one time
in order to not create a potential
staffing shortage
the cobin 19 vaccines will not be
released
until it is they are deemed safe and
effective
but these common side effects are an
important consideration while we all
work to protect the health of our
communities
once a vaccine is approved we anticipate
weekly allocations
and each county will be able to submit
their request for the vaccine
these requests and the monitoring of
vaccination and distribution will run
through nevada's immunization
information system
nevada webid the nevada web ic system is
widely used by nevada's immunizing
providers and nevada state law requires
that all vaccines given in the state
must be entered into the system
this is the system that the immunization
program uses every day
for influenza vaccine in the vaccines
for children program
we are able to track how much vaccine
has been used and how much is still left
on hand
the program is working hard to be
prepared to get the vaccine to our
immunizing providers once it has been
approved
and we are updating nevada's vaccine
playbook with additional details
thoughtfully planned to support this
response
thank you i again want to thank shannon
candice and their entire team
for their tireless work on this
vaccination rollout plan
this rollout is unlike any other and i
am proud of the work they have done to
engage with state and local officials
to be prepared for this moment i want to
conclude with one more quote from this
week's white house report
an important message that must be heard
by all nevadans
the re the coveted risk to all americans
is at
a historic high it must be made clear
that if you are over 65
or have significant health conditions
you should not
enter any indoor public spaces where
anyone is
unmasked due to the immediate risk to
your health
you should have your groceries and
medications delivered
if you are under 40 you need to assume
you became infected during the
thanksgiving period
if you gathered beyond your immediate
household
mostly like you will not most likely you
will not have symptoms
however you are dangerous to others and
must isolate away from anyone at
increased risk
for severe disease and get tested
immediately
if you are over 65 or have significant
medical conditions
and you gathered outside of your
immediate household
you are at significant risk for serious
covet infection
if you develop any symptoms you must be
tested immediately
as the majority of therapeutics work
best
in early infection and before i conclude
i want to mention
a few other things i want to have a
special shout out to our
front line health care workers our
doctors our nurses our technicians
our maintenance folks in the hospitals
everyone that is working in our
hospitals and our healthcare facilities
the national guard that have been
instrumental
in providing the the copa tests
and providing food from the food banks
to various agencies
and they're helping us navigate our way
through this
pandemic the lab staffers all the front
line workers whether they're truck
drivers or grocery store workers or
restaurant workers
that put themselves on the front line
serving all of us during this pandemic
and as it relates to the hospital the
field hospital that was built at renown
the hospital is real the comments that
were made by the president of the united
states were not helpful
i have seen the hospital patients are
being treated in that hospital
and we have our front care health line
workers working
every day in that hospital to protect
people's health
particularly in washoe in northern
nevada
at this time i'll be able to take some
questions i'll turn it over to my staff
to coordinate the media questions and
and
question and answer period
thank you governor this is megan delaney
the comms director
i am just going to um make sure i have
all the correct folks
in the spotlight here
which i do not think i have done
correctly so thank you everyone for a
bit of patience
we will use the chat and raise hand
function so if you could raise your hand
and then we'll call on you
one at a time
great we'll go to sam metz from the ap
it's the first to raise hand
hi governor thanks for taking my
question first of all you sound a lot
better which
i'm happy about um so the original
vaccine playbook said the number one
criteria for tier distribution
was level of exposure but retail workers
were ahead of inmates and long-term care
facility residents
can you explain that and does it have to
do with the composition of the economy
or
the power of interest groups
representing labor
okay and i'm going to divert the most of
the vaccine questions directly to
shannon and canada since they've been
involved in the uh
discussion so if one of you want to
handle that and you want me to jump in
let me know
i can take that one um we have
adjusted our tier structure and we'll be
following
the advisory committee on immunization
practices as it is released
for their recommendations but we will be
releasing a newer version of our
playbook that will have adjusted some of
those tiered numbers and structure
okay
thank you sam sorry about that we'll go
to jon sadler of the las vegas sun for
the next question john
hi governor how are you good john thank
you appreciate it
yeah um i was wondering do we have a
timeline on when we may be able to get
into
tier two i know we're very early in this
but when would somebody
outside of these uh populations in the
first year be able to maybe well
i'll i'll let shannon and candace take
that one too unfortunately we don't know
the size of tier one yet
so it's gonna depend how many
vaccinations how many doses were you
need to get through tier one but
shannon or candice go ahead
yeah yeah yeah
governor i think you are correct we have
to wait on our final allocation numbers
to get us through december and then
we'll be able to know more about how
moving through that tiered process
megan thanks for the question we'll go
to megan messerly from the nevada
independent for the next question
megan thanks so much for doing this
governor and echoing
sam's comments glad that you're you're
feeling better
so turning away from the vaccination
conversation a bit
into the rising case numbers the cdc
today
again urged americans not to travel over
the holidays
other states have issued travel
advisories recommended that visitors
quarantine upon arrival to their states
or in the case of hawaii
put in place testing requirements for
visitors i have two questions related to
this
one is nevada considering putting any of
those policies in place
and two should tourists wanting to come
to las vegas in the coming weeks follow
the cdc's guidance not to travel over
the holidays
well i can again i'm going to reiterate
that our resort partners have a very
robust
uh mitigation situation in place they're
following all the protocols that we have
they helped develop some of the
protocols the gaming control board
has been instrumental in terms of
enforcing those
i don't know what we're looking at in
the future i said a week ago that
we're going to have to look at
everything in two weeks and we're going
to do that
but it is not my intent right now to put
a travel ban on or any travel
restrictions to the state of nevada it's
a
again it's a difficult situation you're
walking in the edge of a knife trying to
balance
the economy and at the same time a
health care system that is being
uh burdened heavily so as i said the
good part is that there the cavalry is
coming there's hope on the horizon here
we've got two vaccines
both of which are going to be delivered
in the next few weeks
and we need to get those out into our
community and and hopefully get them
continued
supplied on a regular basis and we get
our way through this
thank you governor we'll go to mary
hines of the review journal next
hi all thank you for taking my question
um can i get some clarity please on tier
one
shannon i think you mentioned
correctional facility staff
are in tier one law enforcement but the
cdc
committee put in their tier one as i
understood it just
health care workers and long-term care
facility residents so in nevada
who who's going to be first in line very
first in line
to get the vaccine and how much of the
vaccine do you expect to get i know you
perhaps
don't have a precise number but do you
have an estimate
um thank you for the question um so our
health care workers and our hospitals
will be the first
the very first to receive the vaccine
that's where a lot of our initial
efforts have
been our our planning assumption is
pro rata allocation based on population
thank you shannon we'll go to um sasha
from channel 8 for the next question
sasha
hi governor uh thanks for taking my
question uh i know that
dr fauci has spoken about on a national
level that in order for a vaccine to be
effective
you know 40 to 50 percent of the
population has to actually receive it so
will there be any regulations
at this point you know on a state level
for health care workers or
really anybody else in you know a public
capacity that will be
required to take the vaccine at any
point in order to keep doing their job
in that same capacity
yeah no we don't plan on putting a
restriction in place that mandates
anybody receive the vaccine i don't know
what
various employers might do as it relates
to that
uh i think if anyone wants to realize
this and people do realize the situation
that we're in
with the pandemic and the restrictions
that are in place and people want to
get away from this uh these restrictions
in this situation that they will
eagerly await for the vaccine i think
the bigger problem we're going to have
is people are going to want to get it as
quick as possible
as opposed to not getting it at all and
i want you to remember and it's
extremely important
when shannon and candace made mention of
the doses that we're going to get
this month that's the first dose that
people are going to get
it's gonna need to be followed up with a
second dose
three or four weeks later depending on
which vaccination it is so
the first dose comes and then three four
weeks later the second dose comes and
and hopefully we'll be on our way by
that point to protecting the entire
population
thank you for the question we'll go to
joe from fox5 joe
joe it looks as though you're unmuted
but i can't hear you if you're asking a
question
okay can you hear me now we can hear you
now jeff okay thanks governor appreciate
the question thank you when do you
estimate the general public will be able
to get the vaccine once the first groups
get it would you categorize
in days weeks or months well i'm going
to let the experts deal with that but
again we're getting into hypotheticals
we don't know how many doses are going
to be in each tranche
of the vaccine that we're going to get
and how big these tranches are that
we're dealing with
the front end the health care workers
public safety that sort of thing
our convalescent home so go ahead
shannon or candace if you
can answer that more go ahead please yes
thank you for the question
uh our planning assumption at this point
in time for the general public
and what we can plan on is um spring to
mid
um 2021 for the general population
thank you for the question um thank you
candace for the answer
we'll go jerry davis this is reno next
thank you can you guys hear me yep
excellent um i'm not sure this might be
a question for ms bennett
um so i'm if i'm correct in
understanding here
the first doses that we'll roll out will
include uh
law enforcement but also correctional
facility staff
if that's the case i'm wondering will
people incarcerated in nevada's prisons
also be among those to get
first doses and if not why not
um we will be looking at vaccinating
inmates i believe on tier two
um so soon uh hopefully
depending on our allocation uh but we
will be focused in on inmates first and
that is because
our excuse me the correctional staff
first and that is because the
correctional staff
move in and out of those facilities um
to work and then back into the community
um and and can increase spread within
that
particular system thank you shannon
thank you for the question um we have
time for a few more
uh miss starbuck from kunr public radio
hi i just have a question i guess about
how what you guys are doing to make sure
that people do get the vaccine
especially with nevada having such low
immunization
rates and then also making sure that
folks come in for their second dose
well and i'm going to turn this from the
experts too but let me say first off
with the
efficacy rates the flu vaccine is
approximately 40 to 50 percent
efficacy this we're talking 95
i mean if you've known somebody that has
suffered or contracted
covid believe me people are going to be
encouraging you
to go get the vaccine uh what we're
going to do is the various
entities are going to uh work with the
individuals that were vaccinated make
sure they get the second vaccine
but i think that there's going to be a
lot of incentive
i mean to feel better and to have that
protection so they will come and get the
second dose but shannon or candice go
ahead
yes thank you governor very much agree
with that and
what i would say is that um you know
that second dose
is really critical but on top of that
you know
we really truly believe in vaccine
confidence and we are really committed
to being transparent and showing this
information and so
as we focus on tier one we've been very
supportive of those individual
groups providing information as it comes
out at the federal level
and as we move into the general
population you know that outreach will
look different but we're still committed
along with our partners who are also
very much committed to building vaccine
confidence
thank you governor um if it's all right
i have four more questions in the queue
right now so we'll move through those
and then we'll pull to a close
sure we'll um go to terry russell next
terry if you could just unmute your
microphone you can leave your video off
and we should be able to hear you
properly
um thank you very much i'm wondering um
the two vaccines
um actually there's more than two but
moderna and pfizer
are two different vaccines moderna does
not require the sub
subzero temperature to store the pfizer
vaccine does
two questions do you guys does the state
get an option of which vaccine they will
get
and is there concern i know you guys
said you had
refrigeration uh for the other vaccine
that needs that
real cold storage in order to be
effective
do are you concerned are you going to
push those to the
urban areas and leave the others to the
rural because i i'm going to
i'm going to assume um it would be very
hard to keep the stuff stored in a in a
rural area
thank you for the question it's it's a
great one um
so no we do not get a choice at the
federal level we do not get to pick and
choose whether
we receive pfizer mederna products um
pfizer it looks like it's coming first
so we are focused on making sure
every single nevada county has access to
that particular vaccine because it's
going to be first and we want to ensure
our healthcare workers are protected as
soon as possible
eventually when we move down the road
and we have both of the products
in the state we would like to be able to
get modern
products because it will be easier for
them as you mentioned
to store and handle um but
that's not where we are going to be at
the beginning and we will treat it as
as such there are and that's a great uh
answer from shannon there are other
differences between the vaccines for
example
the uh minimum i think on the pfizer
vaccine is 975. that could be sent
to a location moderna is a hundred
so in some of the smaller areas we're
not going to be able to ship
975 and not have them be used so
the team has done an incredible job
working through these differences
these intricacies of the distribution
and it's our goal to get as many vaccine
vaccines avail as we can get and get
them out as quickly as we can
in the community and assure everybody
get that second one at the same time
so go ahead megan thank you governor
thank you shannon we'll go to dana
gentry of the nevada current
for the next question and then we'll
have two more after dana
hi governor thank you for taking my
question i'm glad to see you are well
can you tell me how large the tier 1
population
is and are you confident enough you know
given the problems that we've had
obtaining all the components for testing
are you confident that you'll receive
the subsequent dose allocation or are
you going to have to stockpile that
initial
allocation and split it basically okay
i'll let that to shannon and candace as
well we are not stockpiling i can tell
you that and we're confident we're going
to get
ongoing shipments because that's a
commitment we've got from the federal
government but
go ahead shannon or candace
so i think both of us can kind of answer
your question for this um
what we're really looking at as the
governor mentioned is a weekly cadence
of allocation
and so um with that being said i think
it's important
um we really will have a very um
specific you know uh moderating that's
that particular process and so we feel
really confident in
understanding um and commuting
communicating both with our community
need
our county need um as that allocation
rolls in
and i'll just hand it over to shannon
thank you candace um we have i'm looking
at our playbook right now we have 173
000 people in tier one the federal
government has
assured us that for every first dose we
will get a second dose to equal that
amount
thank you for that um we'll go to victor
jakes of the rj and then um
brenna goth i believe from bloomberg
will take the last question so victor
thank you hey governor yesterday good
i'm glad you're doing well
thank you i appreciate that as i'm sure
you saw yesterday the nevada hospital
association said that quote on and off
again closures appear to be building
animosity and apathy among the public
and are proving ineffective end quote do
you agree or disagree with the hospital
association's assessment
well i i don't think that they meant it
the way that some people are
interpreting that we've got a great
relationship with the hospital
association
clearly uh yes people are frustrated
with what's happening i get that i get
that every single day i mean we've
had everything shut down we opened it
back up we had to take a step back again
uh people have if it's called covet
fatigue whatever it is
we're doing the best we can and it's a
difficult situation again balancing
the economic side and i'm counting the
schools as part of the economic side and
the
well-being side with the strain on our
health care system
and we're doing the best we can to
possibly manage that
uh it's i can't say enough about our
front-line healthcare workers i mean
they are out there
every day i talk to folks that have not
had a day off in four five
six seven months i mean they're working
every single day they're taking extra
shifts
because they know that we so desperately
need the care but
we are working closely with the hospital
association and
they're on the same page ire there is no
silver bullet
to end this if i could say look you
whatever it was if you
uh did this uh procedure
you handled this protocol it would solve
this for sure that doesn't exist
it's a culmination it's a summation of a
lot of different things small things
that can make a difference
and the vaccine is the most uh
optimistic beneficial thing that's
coming along and we've got that on the
horizon but
we work closely with the hospital
association will continue to do so
thank you governor thank you for the
question victor we'll do the final
question from brenna
hi thanks for taking my question i'm
wondering
with the initial doses of vaccine that
nevada expects to receive in december
if you can explain a little bit about
the types of impacts we could see in the
short term
from that you know is that something we
could see affect case numbers or maybe
improve case numbers
fairly quickly or is that something
we're going to have to wait a while to
see the impacts of
go ahead shannon or candice you want to
take that and then i can add some things
at the end
absolutely thank you for the question um
i think
to understand the the dose series is
really important
to answer your question and so those two
days two doses are critical so for the
pfizer
vaccine we're looking at a 21 day
minimum interval
for the moderna we're looking at a
28-day minimum interval
and it's critical to have both of those
doses to get the full immune response
and the other thing it doesn't take
effect and candace or shannon correct me
here
the day you get the vaccine immunity
does not exist
there's a time lag i think it's a month
after the first one
till that there's some uh level
of immunity that's been provided to you
as a result of that so
this is not going to happen it's like a
magical wand getting waved where you go
in and you get the vaccine and suddenly
you're immune
there's going to be a time involved here
but we're
uh positive that once we get this moving
it'll continue to move and build
momentum and we'll get more and more
people involved and then they'll get the
second dose and
more people are going to be included and
we'll get through everybody as quickly
as possible
thank you for the question governor we
will go ahead and pull to a close
if you have any closing comments thank
you everyone for joining us
as shannon and candace mentioned we will
have an updated copy of the playbook
to send to our media partners and the
public after we pull this press
conference to a close
i want to thank everybody for joining us
particularly shannon candice for being
so helpful in answering so many of the
technical questions
as related to the vaccine but i want to
stress
to the uh general public that
things are looking a lot better you know
our numbers haven't been great i get
that
everybody understands that but we have
hope now
a vaccine is coming within weeks we will
begin
distributing and giving people needle
sticks
i mean that's a positive thing this has
been done in record time
and it's our hope that we can get as
much of this as we can out in the
general public
we'll build more and more immunity and
we can start to get back to our regular
lives and
it's our hope that all the vans and i
think more nevadans want to get the
vaccine than don't
and we're going to have a shortage on
that side not people not wanting to get
it so
in the meantime we need to continue
doing everything that we were doing
wearing masks practicing the social
distancing
washing your hands avoiding large
gatherings those
things all make a difference that will
help us build the bridge
stronger to get to the other side where
there'll be enough
vaccine available for everybody that
wants it to get it
and hopefully that'll be sooner rather
than later so thank you for joining me
we appreciate it and have a great night
everyone